[Music]
good morning everybody it's seven
o'clock in the united kingdom two days
left to get a deal at cop26 and the
biggest polluter on the planet is
talking green the chinese president
acknowledges the damage that climate
change will do to his country new claims
of the millions made by the conservative
mp to jeffrey cox in his additional
legal work will speak to the small
business minister paul scully about that
and an apology from the duchess of
sussex who says she forgot her assistant
was cooperating with the authors of a
biography about her life
we'll meet the incredible bionic mum
she's going back to work as a primary
school teacher after losing her arms and
legs through a viral infection and
hitting the pause button will introduce
you to dog tv which aims to de-stress
your
four-legged buddy
it's armistice day thursday the 11th of
november
we will eventually harm ourselves the
chinese president says further action
needs to be taken on climate change as
the cop 26 summit in glasgow reaches its
final stages
there are just two days left here in
scotland for ministers and diplomats to
reach a deal if they stand a chance of
saving the world from a climate
catastrophe
just hours after the prime minister
defends his handling of the sleaze
scandal new allegations about the
lucrative second jobs held by
conservative mp sir jeffrey cox
new rules mean by today all care home
staff in england have to be double
vaccinated but that deadline means many
could lose their jobs
megan's apology the duchess of sussex
says she forgot her aide was cooperating
with the authors of a book about her
life inside the royal family
border chaos poland accuses belarus of
state terrorism as thousands of refugees
tried to cross the border between the
two countries
[Music]
good morning everybody hopes for a deal
on emissions at the cop 26 summit will
be high this morning after the chinese
president publicly admitted the damage
climate change will do to his country in
a speech to a regional summit xi jinping
said the harms done to nature will
eventually harm ourselves there are just
two days left for negotiators to reach
an agreement in glasgow let's find out
more about it it should be ashna has
been there for us throughout joins us
now this is a breakthrough isn't it
ashley good morning
good morning kay it is okay it is a
significant moment the fact that the
countries the world's two biggest
polluters have come together in this way
the united states and china we've heard
at this press conference yesterday
the climate envoy for the u.s john kerry
speaking that he had been having
meetings with china from all the way
back in april and this is what cop is
about is about laying the groundwork
numerous meetings and leading up to this
quite significant moment that they have
agreed on this framework for climate
solutions they say they want to
decarbonize the world and they say they
want to invest in new technology and
come up with these climate solutions but
speaking at a summit an economic summit
the chinese president xi jinping this is
pre the announcement
announced that he was in fact taking
climate seriously here's what he had to
say
it had come to me
that
harm's done to nature will eventually
harm ourselves
china will actively promote
ecological
and lush mountains are invaluable assets
we will intensify comprehensive efforts
to stem soil erosion and win the
critical battle of pollution prevention
and control china will fully implement
its national strategy on climate change
response
since i announced the goals of carbon
peak and carbon neutrality last year
china has formulated an action plan for
carbon dioxide peaking before 2030.
look at that sort of language from the
chinese president this is not um
something that he is used to talking
about we're not used to hearing china
talking in this way about the threat
that climate poses to the entire world
what we've also seen overnight kay are a
new batch of documents that have come
through full of legalese as you can
imagine we've also had that first draft
of the agreement that they hope they
will be released in the next 24 to 48
hours lots of those documents involving
a conversation around finance but also
transparency too as i um pick that i
hope to bring you more details in the
next hour but it is going to be
complicated and pressure is absolutely
ramping up today yep nobody better than
you to um unpack it for us though i
shall see you in the next hour thanks
very much indeed thanks a lot latest gdp
figures have just been released let's
find out more about it our economics and
data editor ed conway is here i know
you're on your way to interview the
chancellor so i've got to make it quick
no well i mean the the numbers have just
come out and that you know he will be
seeing from them for the same time uh at
the same time as us 0.6 growth in
september remember with these gdp
numbers actually in the past we've
tended to look at quarterly numbers but
now we get them on on the month so we
get more of a kind of up-to-date sense
on how the economy is doing 0.6 that's
actually a bit better than expected but
here's the thing they've revised the
previous month down and the big picture
here is that we're still below so the
size of the economy and what we're
talking about is gdp it's just how much
income we're generating across the
economy it gets divided between all of
us that total size of that income pot is
still 0.6 percentage points below where
we were before the pandemic struck so
we're still kind of trying to to regain
that level and some people had hope
maybe this was the moment we might get
back there you know it was touch and go
but this certainly that hasn't happened
we're still trying to kind of regain
that lost ground so that's one of
certainly one of the things i'll talk to
the chancellor about obviously the fact
that people are feeling more and more
squeezed at the moment i mean prices are
really mounting and obviously it's
energy prices but it's also stuff we're
seeing in the shops as well so there's a
lot of big issues in the economy right
now alongside you know what you're
discussing there with ashna about cobb
and what's going on so yeah and we're
just doing actually as you were saying
about a cop just quick thought on that
before you go i know you've got to rush
um how important is it to this
government that they have a successful
outcoming car i mean it matters
enormously it matters enormously because
you know it's rare that actually you
know the uk gets to hold these kinds of
events and this is you know a big moment
for the uk from that perspective uh it's
it is a critical point i think because
you know last time around it was very
much about setting out targets this time
it's actually showing that you can do
something you know it's doing something
and turning those words into actions has
always been the key kind of question
mark over this cop and so far
do we think they've got there i mean
we've got more words from china and the
us which is encouraging but again it's
not about words it's about deeds and
this is supposed to be the moment where
those those deeds are actually supposed
to become concrete we haven't
necessarily got a sign of that yet but
we'll see i mean all these summits if
you've covered plenty of them at sfi i
mean it's it's always very much the last
minute can something be kind of grasp
them from the the jaws of defeat see
your interview with the chancellor
shortly for now ed thanks so much indeed
joining us now is the minister for small
business that's paul scully hello to mr
scully thanks for joining us on the
programme this morning talking about the
prime minister there being on the world
stage at cop
how embarrassing is it for him to be
standing on the world stage at cop and
having to say that the uk is not a
corrupt country
well what you've seen the over cop is
the uk taking and the pm taking great
leadership in what is really really
important for the planet not just that
not just the country but clearly in
terms of what's happening in parliament
uh we're working through we want to get
a cross-party consensus to make sure
that we can root out root out um
the bad practices of mps and making sure
that we're concentrating on our
constituencies concentrating on the
country and concentrating on those
policies that are really important for
people at home
yeah and in answer to my question how
embarrassing is it
well as i say that you know prime
minister is answering direct questions
that that uh that are given to him by
journalists but what he's also doing is
say focusing on what's really important
to people at home and that's making sure
that we can get mps concentrated on that
but in cop in glasgow making sure we can
get the international community as
you've just heard including china and
america now
really focused on on making sure that we
can keep to that one and a half degrees
centigrade increase
okay what motivates you to be an mp
change i wanted to be a local mp in my
local area in sutton uh to get my a new
hospital built and that's uh that's well
on its way now with half a billion
pounds to going and building a new
hospital but also making sure that we
can get opportunity for people i've been
self-employed for 30 years created my
own businesses created jobs myself and i
want to make sure that we can really
embed that in uk culture to allow it to
grow to allow it to develop and make
sure that we've got opportunities for
everybody around the country
okay so that's what motivates you one
senior conservative mp has made five and
a half
million pounds in other work while he's
been an mp in the house of commons why
would you want to be an mp if he can
make that sort of money on the side
well everybody has different motivations
for um to be a member of parliament
everybody has different background
there are a number of people with other
jobs uh many of which actually do
contribute to their to their work as an
mp you know you've got uh you have
lawyers which help them actually then
scrutinize the legislation that we're
passing you have nurses that are keeping
their registration going that can
feedback in uh in in terms of their date
their real life experiences but uh you
know it's it's not for me to comment on
uh individuals financial positions
why not
why not
well because that's up to them and it's
also you know if someone's been accused
of wrongdoing then there are standards
procedures in place for that but
ultimately asking you about wrongdoing
but no what i'm not at all no no what is
this
million quid on the side why bother
being an mp that was my question to you
you've told me what motivates you and
it's very horrible but i'm saying some
of your colleagues who might be sat next
to you or not um are making that sort of
money and one you must sit there and
think what's the point if you being here
you're hardly ever here anyway usually
in the british virgin islands
what i was going to go on to say okay it
ultimately it's the lecturer that's
there to do that you know i've had the
electorate put faith in me three times
now uh and i'm open i'm transparent and
as our um every mp because we have a of
interest it's it's um there for all um
uh voters to be able to see what their
mp is saying for them speaking about on
on their behalf how they're voting uh
and also their register of interest and
that's that's they should be the ones
that are the judge jury and executioner
at the ballot box um come the election
time
um is being an mp not a full-time job
well it depends on where you're going
with this because actually what i hear
from um
one of the arguments about not having a
second time second job is about the time
now i'm a minister and actually over the
last 19 months as you can imagine this
business minister that's taken an
extraordinary amount of my time but now
clearly some of that has a
an impact on my local constituency as
well but time wise i think you you can
actually compartmentalize your time as
i've done but it really depends on what
you're doing you shouldn't be
a paid advocate for anybody in
parliament that's what i meant about
wrongdoing that's what needs to be
rooted out
yeah and we weren't talking about that
this morning we've dealt with that quite
a lot including with owen patterson um
when you said i think it was uh one of
your colleagues certainly said 10 days
ago it's a storm in a tea cup and
still talking about it there won't be
it's a rather a big storm
well as i say i think there was a that
was someone else talking about owen
patterson but nonetheless you know as as
often happens there are stories that
sitting within journalists pockets that
they bring out at times like this and uh
but it's really important that we get it
right well you say it's journalist's
fault that
the corrupt politicians are taking money
when they shouldn't be i'm sure you're
not saying that for one second are you
no no but you're
talking about terrifying
look no owen pat owen patterson was it
was one case and that has been rooted
out he's obviously resigned the
situation that you're talking about
today is not about people taking money
wrongly it's about whether they should
have been having second jobs and what
the so that's it it's a different
conversation but it but an important con
but an important one and asked you about
it
whether it was a storm and a teacup or
not do you stand by your comments then
that the comments that you made
about owen patterson and this being
nothing more than a case of labor
playing party politics that's what you
said at the time
yeah what i said about that was that was
the widening of the discussion um as
at in question time last week it wasn't
about owen patterson it was actually
about a lot of series of accusations
that that people were conflating with
the owen patterson case because what you
tend to find in moments like this
is that it does widen out to other
parties i've seen issues like kia
stammer for example to um making
money giving legal advice and he hasn't
said who he's given legal advice to uh
in the previous years we've got ed davey
that's behind a consultancy so lots of
different parties are declaring outside
interests but it just damages the
politics body if you like and sometimes
trust in parliamentarians that's that's
what i was trying to say but nonetheless
we've got to get this right so that
people electors can actually see what
their mps are doing on their behalf and
why and they can make the decision and
they can hold their mps to account
is it okay for an mp
um to be in the british virgin islands
for weeks on end rather than
representing his constituents
well i'm not i'm not going to uh defend
geoffrey or i'm not going to say
anything that's that's up to jeffrey
that's between him and his voters we've
had an odd situation i must admit over
the last year
is it because you're a member you're a
minister you're more senior than he is
how do you feel about one of your uh mps
uh being in the british virgin islands
sunning himself or whatever he's doing
while his constituents are trying to get
him on the phone and they can't
well i i don't know whether they've been
able to contact him or not i don't know
whether he's been stunning himself so
that's why it's not appropriate for me
to comment on on partial information but
nonetheless as i say the voters can see
exactly uh what he or what any mp has
and hasn't been doing we've been in an
odd situation over the last um few
months during the pandemic because
pretty well every mp had a proxy vote
and so we weren't able to come in freely
into parliament over that period with
the the hybrid situation that we had but
nonetheless that's gone back to normal
now uh i expect um uh mp's attendance to
go back to normal as well okay you can
appreciate can you not that the optics
are not good
or are you guys like completely linked
and can't even acknowledge that no
okay no absolutely i can see exactly how
it looks and it's really regrettable
that uh that we've got to this situation
um what i would say is that politicians
from all sides that i see that i meet um
are
in it for the right reasons they want to
make a positive difference to their uh
residents in their constituencies and
indeed the country as a whole
okay what is it that's regressible just
to clarify
well that we've got in a position that
first of all last week that we uh
allowed the situation from one
individual to be conflated with uh the
standards procedures which do need um
looking at they do need an appeals
process but we in the in order to do
that we need a cross-party consensus um
but then as i say for um a number of
other other issues to be conflated which
we need to tackle but we need to tackle
in a level-headed way
uh and and certainly not get into a
party political ban fight
well it's not really is this one of your
colleagues is you know selling himself
in the british virgin islands but um
come the next election we'll see what
happens well final question before i let
you go will care home staff be um
allowed to turn up for work today if
they're not double jabbed
well i mean the rules are that today is
the deadline for uh for um uh those uh
those double um jabs to to have happened
it's important that we protect the uh
uh the people within care homes we've
seen the um the the difficulty of doing
that during the height of the pandemic
and um we've obviously extended that to
nhs frontline workers but you'll need to
speak to the uh to to those people
within the care homes to uh to get
detailed further details of exactly
what's going to happen at this moment in
time well what do you expect to happen
if they turn up for work what should
happen to them
well i think there's a level of
expectations they've had 12 weeks to
have had their uh to have their
vaccination i would i would um hope and
expect that uh that those people would
have that duty of care to the people
that they are there to serve and to
protect those people the the most
vulnerable in our society the the people
that are most likely to be hospitalized
and i'm afraid to die of covid that's
what that measure has been all about and
that's what why we're determined to make
sure that continues so they should be
turned away at the door leaving their
colleagues to struggle looking after the
very people that you've just been
talking about
well i'm not sure it's a matter of
people being turned away at the door
okay it's something that's happened over
the last 12 weeks that uh that people in
social care
have
known um uh and had plenty of warning
about and i would hope that
that they would have gone out and got
those got those vaccinations to keep the
people that they work for safe
okay have you ever been to the british
virgin islands
no
would you like to do not at all
would you like to know maybe sometime i
bet i've barely been i've barely been
out of the country so yeah for the for
the last couple of years so uh i'm i'm
way too busy to uh to even think about
volume trip at the moment and there we
have it it's good to talk to you thanks
very much indeed for joining us on the
programme this morning thank you still
to come on the programme for you this
morning the brains of london cabbies are
being studied as part of research into
treating alzheimer's later this hour
we'll speak to a neuroscience professor
who will also speak to a black cabbie
about why there's such a shortage of
drivers
their demanding fertility equality will
speak to the same sex couple taking
legal action against their local nhs
group over its ivf treatment policy
and we'll discuss the ongoing sleaze
allegations with the shadow housing
secretary lucy powell
now as you heard new rules come into
force this morning meaning that all care
home staff in england must be double
jabbed against coronavirus
let's speak to uh sadia who is standing
by in liverpool for us this morning hi
sadie what's going to happen there
good morning while the minister was
there talking about protection
protecting care home residents well care
homes will say they need to be fully
staffed in order to be able to do that
and i'm at a care home in liverpool
where they've lost seven percent of
their staff members because of their
vaccination status and let me just tell
you a bit about what these uh
workers would have done they're called
support workers they would have been in
charge of things like personal care so
feeding and bathing
their guests here well we can go over
now and speak to normandy rag she's the
ceo of st joseph's care homes thank you
very much for joining us first of all
tell us what is the impact on care home
residents
well we always try to keep really safe
safe safe staffing numbers so this will
have an impact but no matter what
happens all the residents that are here
at st joseph will be safe but it will
put some extra stress
on the existing staff members who have
been so very good throughout the
pandemic and who are just a bit tired
now
um and what about in terms of replacing
these stuff is that easy to do right now
we're having some challenges with
recruitment all across the country
health and social care is having some
challenges we will have challenges with
recruitment recruitment and safer
recruitment checks do take time we have
to make sure we get the right type of
people into the right roles and so it
will have an impact on us without a
doubt
amazing thank you very much for speaking
to us well as you hear the challenges
not just here at this care home but
likely to be something that we see
across care homes across the country
okay thank you thanks a lot
also this morning for you the duchess of
sussex has apologized to a court for
forgetting that she asked a senior aide
to brief the authors of a book about her
the revelation came during a hearing
brought by the owners of the mail on
sunday who were appealing against a
ruling over publishing a letter from the
duchess to her father
richard ratcliffe the husband of nazanin
zagar who ratcliffe is today starting
the 19th day of his hunger strike he's
calling on the government to do more to
bring his wife home
from iran
let's talk to the former foreign
secretary now chair of the health and
social
committee and that is jeremy hunt of
course mr hunt thanks for joining us on
the programme this morning we chatted
to richard earlier on in the week and he
was not in good shape when is this going
to be resolved
well i saw him yesterday and first thing
to say is he is an incredibly brave man
and he's brave for two reasons firstly
because he is doing everything possible
to get nazinin released but secondly
because he's the first person in this
situation and there have been many over
the years who's gone public about it and
so the world knows about iran's hostage
taking and i hope one of the things that
comes out of this
is that
iran and other countries that are
thinking of doing this in the future are
shamed into not doing so because it is
an outrageous thing in the 21st century
that countries actually take innocent
people hostage in order to get their way
on diplomatic issues
why when you were foreign secretary did
you not organize for this 400 million
quids worth of debt that we owe the
iranians to be sorted out and then she
could come home
well that is the heart of the issue and
i did make a lot of efforts uh in that
direction i went to tehran
to meet the then foreign minister to try
and understand what was blocking her
release um and i think we have moved on
now
when i was foreign secretary there was a
debate about the principle of it
and we established that this is not
paying ransom money if it was paying
rats money i wouldn't support paying it
this is paying a debt that an
international court has said we owe
the defense secretary has said we owe
and i think there is now no argument
about the principle of it it's difficult
iran is a is a horrible regime that does
the most despicable things so it doesn't
make anyone comfortable doing it but now
it's about the mechanics they are
sanctioned it's not totally easy it is
doable and we've just got to get on and
do it
so we should pay them
we should absolutely pay them because
this is a debt and we are a country that
pays its debts and even if
it is a totally unsavory regime we
should pay this debt uh there should be
no linkage whatsoever between this and
the case of by the way not just nazanin
but anushia shuri murad tabaz both
wonderful people both innocent both
people who have got incredibly
supportive and very very distressed
families and you know this is definitely
an impediment in the relationship
and whether or not iran sees there to be
a linkage we need to solve this issue
anyway and we should get on and do it
i think there's a meeting today isn't
there with the iranian deputy um fm what
should come from that
well this is actually really good news
it's encouraging uh this deputy foreign
minister is over here because of cop 26
and and i think that
what uh the reason that we're encouraged
about this is that when i was foreign
secretary we always asked ourselves
whether it was a waste of time talking
to the foreign ministry because the
government in iran was really controlled
by the hardliners the revolutionary
guards who reported to the supreme
leader
but now the hardliners have actually
taken over the government so ironically
it might be more productive talking to
the foreign ministry because they might
be speaking to the whole of the
government including the people who are
holding naznin hostage
um you were also health secretary you've
had lots of titles as part of this
government
and you're now chair of the health and
social care committee where are you
where are you as far as uh double jabbed
um staff uh no longer being able to work
from today in care homes
i think it's a very difficult issue um
the practical issue is you know what is
going to be the impact of some people
leaving as they undoubtedly do
but i do support it because in the end
if your
mum or your dad is in a care home or
indeed in a hospital
i think you have a right to know that
everyone taking care of him or her
has taken trouble to make sure they're
not spreading a disease asymptomatically
it is the first responsibility of every
doctor nurse or carer and every single
one that i know has been jabbed twice so
i think it is the right thing to do it
will keep patients safer but i do
recognize there are some practical
challenges
of course you can still pass on kovid
even if you have been double jabbed even
if you've also had your booster is daily
testing not a better option
yes but you know daily testing is not
foolproof either
the one thing you can do that you know
will make a big difference is to get
jabbed and i think that
people working in health and care do
understand that and they want to put the
safety and the protection of the
vulnerable people that they after all
given their lives to looking after they
want to put that first so
look it's a really difficult issue it's
difficult in the care sector it's
difficult in the nhs but i do think
sajid javed is right to have bitten the
bullet on it
you're a senior member of the party the
government how embarrassing is it for
our prime minister to be standing up on
the world stage and saying we are not a
corrupt country
well um
you know i'm not a member of the
government but i am a conservative mp
i'm proud to be a conservative mp and
all i would say to
anyone who is laughing at britain uh
laughing at our democracy anywhere in
the world is it is because people like
you are asking people like me these kind
of difficult questions we have one of
the most active vibrant toughest media
scrutineer politicians anywhere in the
world that we are actually less corrupt
than most countries and that's not to
say we're perfect that's not to say we
get everything right but the fact is we
are a very open robust democracy and i
think ultimately that is actually to our
credit
with that in mind you were there during
the expenses scandal how similar is this
i think it's one of those things where
one or two elements of wrongdoing may
cause the rules to be changed
and i think
there are some gray areas where there
needs to be more clarity
we know that you're not allowed to do
private business from parliamentary
premises
does that apply if someone calls you on
your mobile for example and you happen
to be in your office in parliament and i
think
what this will do is mean those kind of
rules are clarified and that's a good
thing
and is it okay to do your business
as an mp from the british virgin islands
well i don't want to talk about that
individual case k um because that's
going to be investigating choose any
place you want let's say majorca is it
okay to work for several weeks away from
parliament
well there are lots of lovely corners of
the world where you know we would um we
would all love to do our work from but
you know i think in this particular case
we we just need to let the investigation
happen and find out whether the rules
were broken
good to talk to you as always mr hunt
thank you
thank you
clinical trials are about to begin on a
new vaccine for ebola one of the world's
deadliest diseases i want to talk about
it in more detail under standing by for
us i think in the newsroom yep there he
is hi ender good morning are your
thoughts on this story this morning
please
yeah morning k well this is day one of
phase one of these clinical trials at
oxford university 26 people aged between
18 and 55 will be given one dose of this
new ebola vaccine they'll be monitored
over six months and we'll get full
results on all the trials second quarter
of next year now if we look at how
they're doing this it's effectively
based on a weakened variation of the
common cold virus
and that has been genetically modified
so there's no prospect of the virus
replicating itself in humans now ebola
has four species in total the two that
are the most dangerous are zaire and
sudan types of ebola
they
really cause very serious complications
for people and zaire in particular has a
fatality rate of between 70 and 90
percent in people when it is not treated
and of course the most recent outbreak
was in 2018 uh when there were some 32
000 people infected in the democratic
republic of the congo thirteen thousand
six hundred of them died so very
significant day at oxford university
another vaccine uh they're trialing and
it's loosely based around the kind of
scientific science and technology that
they used for the astrazeneca job
okay thank you
a quick look at the weather very quick
look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
conditions across the country will
remain divided north to south before
cloud rain and strong winds spread in
from the atlantic tomorrow evening
a quiet start to the day with slack
winds whatever that means causing mist
and fog to linger in places
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
more incredible pictures for you now
emerging from the volcanic eruption in
la palma
here we go
homes garden furniture and buildings
covered in ash oh my goodness me as the
eruption continues it's been more than
five weeks since the comrade vieque
first erupted in september and uh
scientists estimate that volcano has so
far thrown out more than 10 000 cubic
meters of rock and magma look at that
poor pussycat
still i'm sure he's fine
uh going to be talking to the scientists
studying the navigational skills of
london's black cab drivers to see if
they could provide a treatment for
alzheimer's next
[Music]
a senior government minister has
expressed regret we're told for the
government's handling of the sleaze
allegations the prime minister was
yesterday forced to insist the uk is not
remotely a corrupt country it comes amid
controversy over conservative mps with
second jobs short time ago the minister
for small business paul scully told me
the situation was regrettable
absolutely i can see exactly how it
looks and it's really regrettable that
uh that we've got to this situation
what i would say is that politicians
from all sides that i see that i meet
are
in it for the right reasons they want to
make a positive difference to their uh
residents in their constituencies and
indeed the country as a whole
zamar is here he also did go on to say
that he was too busy to go to the
british virgin islands yes interesting
that he didn't defend geoffrey cox now
he does again in the papers because um
newspapers have totted up how much he
made from his legal work over the whole
time he's been an mp which he's been
perfectly open about and declared
properly and it's five and a half
million pounds now
none of that is against the rules the
only breach of the rules that he's
accused of is using his commons office
for that work but other mps not not
rushing to his defense and the reason
for that is because while a lot of mps
particularly conservative mps it must be
said do you make money from outside
sources he makes the most and he also
has not spoken in parliament so in the
last 18 months he's only spoken once and
i think that is what is really galling
downing street and a lot of mps about
this issue that there is um there is a
line of appropriateness somewhere and
not speaking in parliament more than
once in 18 months is possibly where it
is
um we also spoke to jeremy hunt actually
um and he had views as well didn't you
yes well um he when he asked him about
whether this is reminiscent of the
expenses scandal and that is what some
mps fear really that this is open to
pandora's box where now
journalists and others are going through
the register of members interest where
all mps have to declare their outside
earnings and say well this mp made there
was an example of one mp lawrence
robertson made 24 000 pounds as an
advisor to the abetting council and
there were there was a time when he
talked about betting in parliament there
are other mps not illegal not illegal
not against the rules everyone every mp
is allowed to take money as long as it's
properly declared they're just not
allowed to lobby ministers or officials
behind the scenes which is what owen
patterson was found to have done so
there are lots of cases now bubbling
away and the feeling is there's no real
end in sight this could just go on for
some time and jeremy hunt said there was
a need to tighten up the rules in grey
areas because for example he said you
could work for an outside business
perfectly legitimately what if they
called you on your mobile phone when you
were sitting in your office in
parliament would that be against the
rules so he's suggesting that the rules
do need a bit of an overhaul okay for
now tomorrow tomorrow's take out at nine
o'clock and looking forward to it thank
you meantime scientists to look at
whether the brains of london's famous
black cab drivers cappies could be used
to find a cure for alzheimer's there are
fame they're famous of course for being
able to use their memory to plot the
quickest route across the capital but
the research comes at exactly the moment
we're being warned the city is running
low on cabbies so joined by the general
secretary of the licensed taxi drivers
association and a black cabbie himself
as well uh steve mcnamara um hi steve
thanks for joining us on the programme
uh this morning so
it's called the knowledge i think isn't
it and as a result apparently it fends
off alzheimer's what do you think
well we're very proud that london's taxi
drivers have got bigger hippo campuses
than everybody else it's not everybody
that can say that
yeah what do you think though about
what actually has to happen as far as
the knowledge is concerned why do you
think that improves your brain power
well what happens you have to spend an
enormous amount of time uh anything up
to three four years
memorizing virtually every street in
london every building every site public
interest restaurant bar club tv studio
and as a result of that you obviously
take on a large amount of knowledge and
the theory is that a certain part of
your brain the hippocampus gets bigger
and
apparently it helps to fend off
alzheimer's um you know quite how true
it is i don't know but to be honest
we've given it a lot of fault we can't
think of many cabbies that have retired
or who actually have outsiders so
perhaps there is something in it
do you be honest now do you use waze and
uh google maps these days
no what often happens is we use those
things as traffic indicators so things
like waves obviously show the traffic
and so do google maps and a lot of
cabbies especially with the recent
number of road closures and stuff often
have those running not to show them the
route but just to show them where the
traffic is and to possibly make a change
you know shortly before or after and of
course what what we rapidly recognize is
those things are often wrong even today
so you know this great technology is no
substitute for knowing where you're
going and the knowledge of london
yeah i'm always absolutely astounded how
if you get in the back of a cab and you
say can you take me here they
immediately know how to get there in the
quickest route as well but there is a
shortage of cabbies isn't there what's
going on
yeah it's it is a bit over exaggerated
to be honest with you but what has
happened during the pandemic when a lot
of taxi drivers had absolutely no
support whatsoever fell through the
holes in the various government schemes
the sei double s and others uh sold cabs
and and left the industry uh and now
that they're returning and they're
returning in numbers what there's a real
shortage of his vehicles um
taxi drivers in london are at the moment
investing over three million pounds a
week in these new electric vehicles but
there's just not enough of them and
there is a shortage of cabs we're down
to 14 000 cabs in london from uh just
over 18 000 at the start of the pandemic
and it is beginning to cause us problems
i was about to ask you about the
electric vehicles where are we with that
are they sort of what the diesel ones
are being phased out and the electric
ones coming in
yeah 35 percent of london's taxi fleet
now is electric um we're adopting this
new green clean technology you know way
ahead of cops um way ahead of anything
else and as i said we're investing 3
million pounds a week these vehicles are
65 000 pounds and uh we're buying them
at a rate of 50 a week and london is
transforming to electric vehicles at a
rate unseen anywhere else in the world
and very shortly london will have not
only the best cab service in the world
but we'll have the cleanest cab service
anywhere in the world
and when do you expect the fleet to be
completely electric
had it not been for the pandemic we were
estimating at the end of 2024
um possibly 25 at some time certainly 90
percent um what we're doing at the
moment as you know we're only sort of
eight weeks back 10 weeks back after the
pandemic so we're being a bit careful
with that um
you know with our predictions but look
the reality is 35 percent of the fleet's
electric at the moment and that's
changing at the rate of 50 a week which
is which is just phenomenal and and just
finally carr would like to reassure your
viewers that i am not in the british
virgin islands
but are you going south of the river
today though
i'm actually talking to you from south
london which
you know there you go so that's another
that's another rumor another rumor
scotch
it's good to talk to you thanks very
much indeed i think that's a
london-centric joke isn't it though
steve thanks a lot appreciate it
thank you thank you
for the rest of us it's apparently what
uh cabbies say i'm not going south of
the river but obviously they do hugo
spires is uh joining us as well he is a
professor of cognitive neuroscience at
ucl university college london thanks for
joining us on the programme so london's
cabbies brains um studied to help fend
off alzheimer's tell us more
yes this is our project taxi brains
we've set up so we're trying to find out
more about the size of their hippocampus
in more detail things have moved on
technologically since 2000 when they
were first studied so we want to see a
bit more detail about how the
hippocampus is shaped and organized we
also want to see more about how they do
that that performance you said they can
just jump you can jump in a cab and i'll
just take you where you need to go
immediately
how do they do that so we've been
looking at how they use their brain and
with brain imaging the activity in their
brain and finally we've as noted in the
piece we're quite interested in
understanding given that the hippocampus
seems to get larger with uh experience
and age in that case and that's unusual
normally our hippocampus tends to
decline a bit so it's really important
for thinking about diseases like
alzheimer's dementia where there is
actually a shrinkage within the
hippocampus as part of that disease
these people seem to hold an important
key to understanding the puzzle of how
we might
examine and understand alzheimer's
disease so we'll be putting them through
a potential future diagnostic tool
it helps us understand more about the
disorientation navigation skills people
have
that they then may be useful for
spotting people who have problems so if
we can understand the absolute experts
and how their brains are are changing um
it may give us insights we need to know
towards the development of potential
tools that detect alzheimer's and then
in the future when we do potentially
have drugs available we might be able to
treat alzheimer's earlier and earlier
and that's really the aim of this
mission
of taxes what can we do what can we do
to try to improve our um brain power i i
often read about sudoku's being a good
idea
yeah there's there's good evidence
keeping your brain active is good and um
as steve said in the piece coming in you
know we don't know whether to extend
what taxi drivers do might be quite
important they have to really think very
hard every day about how they can plan
routes through 26 000 streets so for the
rest of us keeping our brains active and
keeping our bodies healthy seems to be a
really key message it's not just keeping
your brain busy but but get out there
get healthy get active
how good are you at sudoku are you any
good
rubbish
as a scientist we're very specialized in
what we're good at and that is not one
of my skills
um crosswords telegraph crossword how
are you on that
yeah again not not my forte more
studying brains and uh thinking through
what's going on inside people's brains
and the structure of brains uh
crosswords are great i do enjoy them but
it's it's um it's quite different but
that that knowledge test the taxi
drivers do is just like on beyond any
possible crazy crossword you could think
of um you know picking two random
streets and working out how you get
exactly on the shortest line between
them
yeah it's pretty impressive isn't it
it's good to talk to you hugo thanks
very much indeed thanks a lot
thank you very much
uh fertility equality will meet the same
sex couple who've started legal action
against the nhs over its ivf treatment
policy not to come
[Music]
now a married same-sex couple has
started legal action against their local
nhs over its fertility treatment policy
they say that the health service is
financially penalizing lgbtq plus
partners
social media influences whitney and
megan bacon evans both with us now hello
to you both thank you very much indeed
for joining us on the program this
morning um not sure who wants to take
the first question but why are you
launching this case
well we're launching this case because
obviously it's very personal to us we
are a lesbian couple we've been together
for 13 years and when we embarked on our
baby journey at the beginning of 2020 we
were shocked to discover there was
various barriers and discrimination in
place against us and ultimately it comes
down to wanting equal access equal
access to facility treatment and it's
the unfair financial burden that has
been placed on the lgbtq plus community
that amounts to the less valuable
treatment
okay so whitney what different how are
you treated differently
um for instance our local ccg which is a
clinical commissioning group they
require same-sex couples um so megan and
i to undergo 12 self-funded rounds of
iui
and if you combine that with the cost of
donor sperm you're looking at
essentially 50 000 pounds you have to
pay just to be on an equal playing field
with a heterosexual couple who the
requirements to um for ivf are two years
of unprotected sex um with no evidence
required so essentially there is you
could call it a gay tax that has been
honest
um and megan
how much does it actually cost you so
far and how do you want to see the
process changed
well at the moment um it's cost us
around 8 000 pounds and actually
majority of that is donor sperm so i
don't know what people realize but that
part is also very expensive as well as
the fertility treatments um and what
we're wanting obviously to happen is for
equal rights to the lgbtq plus community
for there to be discrimination to be
recognised and ultimately for us to be
treated as equal
what that looks like is obviously not
entirely down to us um but to be on an
equal
similar level would be iui being
provided that level of insemination in
the first step and then ivf this is
actually something that scotland already
provide
whitney have you had much support in
your action
yes we've had an overwhelming amount of
support
it is absolutely wonderful to see how
many people um who have reached out with
a positive response and meg and i also
realized you know this just does not
affect us it affects the whole community
and it just shows there is such a need
um for what we're really campaigning for
so megan what happens now
well it's been our case has been issued
to the digital court um for review and
then we are just literally waiting to
hear so
keep posted
yeah well fingers crossed how important
is it uh whitney to you both to be able
to to have a family
oh it's very important as megan said
we've been together for 13 years um just
loving my life so we always envisioned
having two little kiddos and we already
picked out the name of our children like
10 years ago so
we're very excited oh i'm desperate to
know what they are tell me
thank you
oh tell me what the name
said
olivia and oscar
olivia and oscar oh those are beautiful
names so how long do you think the
process might take
um for us to get pregnant or for the
case
for the whole case to uh proceed to um
so that you can find yourself in a
position where you can have olivia and
oscar
well at the moment um our lawyers are
hoping that the court hearing may take
place in january um but all depends if
it is agreed to be expedited so um
obviously we know it's going to be
months but how many we don't know yet
okay well i think it's i think um it's
reasonable to say that when you do
finally have those little ones given how
beautiful their moms are they're going
to be very handsome children thank you
very much indeed for joining us on the
programme much appreciated thank you
thank you thank you thanks a lot
well the fertility services we provide
this is a statement are based on nice
guidance while we can't comment on
individual cases this uh
we will fully engage with any legal
proceedings this is from the nhs
friendly clinical commissioning group
good look at the weather for you
you